volver a los confinamientos totales ese
temor que rondaba a europa y muchos
países se está haciendo realidad en
francia el aumento de las restricciones
ha sido progresivo las autoridades
decidieron que ya no será útil una
prueba rápida para entrar al país desde
el próximo lunes el país galo exigirá a
los ciudadanos de fuera de la unión
europea un examen pcr que tarda más que
la prueba de antígenos y se extendió dos
horas el toque de queda nocturno ahora
irá desde las seis de la tarde hasta las
seis de la mañana en todo el país al
menos durante quince días
estoy a favor de una pcr a la salida y
una pcr al regreso creo que si todo el
mundo se hiciera una bcr 72 horas antes
de una salida y de una llegada podríamos
prever una circulación fluida de las
poblaciones al menos en europa
monago está desde hoy ninguna persona
que vuele desde 14 países sudamericanos
portugal ni cabo verde podrá entrar en
reino unido el gobierno británico así lo
decidió luego de que se confirmara una
nueva variante del cob y 19 en la
amazonía brasileña
portugal inicia este viernes un nuevo
confinamiento nacional por lo menos
hasta el 30 de enero sólo funcionarán
las escuelas y los servicios básicos
las restricciones disminuirán el 24 de
enero por las elecciones presidenciales
eso es lo que tenemos que hacer eso es
lo que nos dijeron no podemos hacer nada
más humano la propagación del brote
también endureció las medidas en países
bajos que extendió su confinamiento
hasta el 9 de febrero y en alemania los
medios estiman que el gobierno considera
prolongar el aislamiento hasta marzo